I'm Paul Coggins and I'm privileged to
be the vice chair of the sixth floor
museum board at Dealey Plaza and we are
extremely privileged to have a special
program tonight with an outstanding
author and before he's not sitting off
there announced any prosecutor Vincent
Bugliosi at Billy OC and I have to tell
you for housekeeping purposes since
c-span is carrying this we really need
you to make sure you've turned off your
phone your beepers your buzzers whatever
you've got unless it's a life-support
system make sure it's turned off and
also it's important that no photography
or recording equipment is permissible at
this program mr. Bugliosi has agreed
after he gives some remarks to do a
question and answer period because of
the shortness of time and the number of
people here you need to restrict it to
one question at that time now it is my
great pleasure to tell you a little bit
about our speaker tonight although his
name has been in the public domain for
as long as I can remember
he graduated from UCLA Law School when
he was at the LA district attorney's
office where he won a staggering 105 out
of 100 six felony trials and as a former
prosecutor I can tell you that's a
pretty good batting average the most
famous case he prosecuted has to have
been the Charles Manson conspiracy
murder trial and as a result of that he
wrote a book called helter skelter which
is still the best-selling true crime
book of all time and was turned into an
outstanding movie a helter skelter in
which i-i-i-i've see our the movie very
well one of the most terrifying movies
I've ever seen and the part of mr. Bruhl
dlc was played by the great actor bruno
kirby now and that really kicked off his
publishing career but he has had a
phenomenal publishing career he has had
three true crime books helter skelter
helter skelter and the sea will tale and
outrage
the five reasons OJ Simpson got away
with murder all three of those books hit
number one on the New York Times
bestseller list and that is a record he
has been hailed for his writing ability
he has been hailed for his skill as a
prosecutor his ability to weave those
worlds together and I will promise you
this the book he's going to talk to you
about tonight his new book I will
promise you it's gonna be his biggest
book of all time because 1,600 pages
plus more pages for exhibits and I and
mr. Bugliosi notice no Court of Appeals
will let you write anything nearly that
long we are honored and privileged to
have mr. Vincent Billy LC here to
address it thank you very much ladies
and gentlemen you know one thing I rail
against in life is incompetence
constantly talk about incompetence
I'm staggered when I find competence
they got a nice little podium here where
the water keeps falling down of course I
got to be you know they say when you get
older you become more what's the word
mild mild mannered or whatever it is
Nowell that's the word I seem to be
getting more sarcastic and so where do
you put this thing I guess I think lose
your okay there's not too much room here
ah the lighting is really great here can
hardly see of course it keeps falling
down I've been extremely extremely busy
today but I got to start early in the
morning I think I've breakfast around 6
o'clock had a candy bar since then what
does it say about how busy I am that the
first time I get to relax during the
whole day is to give a speech at night
really I'm relaxing now because I can
take my time you go on these shows and
they say we want to cover this and cover
that and fine they even want to talk to
me about Manson how long do we have all
about two and a half minutes
I want to say man whoever put this
together it's just unbelievable I want
to say that I'm certainly very honored
that I've been invited to speak here at
the sixth floor Museum tonight and the
building were at all happen we're on the
seventh floor
all right okay well some of you don't
believe that Oswald on the sixth floor
is the one that fired the shots that
altered the course of world history but
I think I proved that beyond all doubt
in reclaiming history and we all know
about Gary Mac where are you Gary yeah
we all know about Gary Mac the
tremendous job he's done as the curator
here at the Museum it's become a
tremendous repository tremendous
repository for assassination related
documents and materials and much of that
achievement is directly attributable to
Gary Mac why don't we give Gary a big
hand I'm gonna have to glance down from
time to time look at my notes one thing
about me that most people say is but
you'll see comes prepared and I always
do prepare everything I say but even
though I wrote them in a million and a
half words here I have not gotten around
yet to writing a formal speech on this
so I did jaws some notes down I'm not as
prepared as I normally would be in
giving a speech but at some point I'm
gonna have to condense these million and
a half pages into a formal speech and I
just don't have time at the moment today
I was at the Dallas Bar Association and
these people were coming up to me and
they'd introduced themselves they said
I'm a former judge a former judge
because I look at them to look young as
young enough they look young and you
know I was a just for 25 years and
they're your former judge and I'm saying
how do I look
if if these people look young to me in
their retired judges I said god I must
look terrible you know I just looked
like I'm 200 years old in fact a lady
came up to me not too long ago and we
got talking she's you know myself I also
you you look
good and I say yeah I don't look like
I'm a day over 19 she said you don't and
she said I don't know I first got
involved in the Kennedy assassination
way back in 1986 when London Weekend
Television called me I'm gonna speak
much more slowly tonight than I have
been during the day I want to relax I'm
getting a speech most people would not
consider giving a speech relaxing but to
me it is
anyway London Weekend Television called
me and said that they were gonna have a
trial of Lee Harvey Oswald and they
wanted me to prosecute Oswald Jerry
Spence the cowboy lawyer from my oming
when I say call by lawyer by the way
that's not in denigration of Jerry
Spence Jerry thinks he's a cowboy he
comes into court you know the Stetson
hat cowboy boots but he's a great lawyer
is one of the great lawyers of our
generation so I'm not speaking in a
denigrating way about him but Jerry
thinks he's a cowboy he has a ranch and
he dresses like a cowboy in fact I have
a photo of him and me at the sixth floor
window before they put as a plastic
glass that what it is that they they put
around it
well Jerry and I were there before that
and we're looking down at the at Elm
Street so they said Spence was gonna
defend Oswald and I would be prosecuting
and my first response was you know I had
been asked in the past to participate in
these artificial or whatever the word
would be that's not quite the word I'm
thinking of when you get my age you
forget the right word but anyway not
real courtroom dramatizations and I
invariably said no and and I told him I
said I don't appreciate it I'm honored
that you thought about me but I said I'm
not interested they said wait awhile now
this is gonna be completely different I
said what do you mean by that he said
well we understand you have a love
affair with your yellow pad and I still
don't have a computer I don't have a
cell phone
still in the 19th century and they said
well your yellow pad is gonna be the
script and I think well that sounds good
dice is not going to be scripted ice
that's great
your yellow pad is gonna be the script
and whatever Spence use is gonna be the
script you are the people that are going
to determine who's called to the witness
stand etcetera we're going to get the
original Warren Commission
the very people that I would need for
instance if I had prosecuted Oswald in
real life how did they get these people
a lot of these people were shutting the
door on the media and they would come to
the door hanging and hanging up on the
phone but there's a little inducement
here two weeks in London and a great
hotel for themselves and their their
spouse so they had convinced the
original Warren Commission witnesses to
testify and we're gonna have a federal
judge from Midland Texas federal jury
chosen from the jury rolls of the Dallas
Federal District Court it was a judge
Bunton it does anyone know judge about
now he's passed away but he was a
Midland okay very good
and they said you're gonna be a trial
for twenty eight hours that didn't sound
too bad to me twenty eight hours maybe
get him to a certain amount of death as
it turned out I was twenty-one hours
when he got over there
so I agreed to do it and Spence and I
went at it for 21 hours in London and I
think Jerry will tell you the same thing
that I will tell you that he and I
worked on this case as much as any other
murder case and our entire career as I
am standing Jerry even had two lawyers
in his law firm working working
full-time on it so we took it very very
seriously
I remember one incident the jury was
asking a witness to comment on something
and the witness said well you know I'm
not going to square it and I'm under
oath you know it seemed as if they
didn't testify to the truth someone was
going to prosecute the perjury but that
showed the state of mind of these people
and I've spoken to the foreman of the
jury everyone took it very very
seriously and Judge button said this was
this was this was it I mean it's close
to real trials possible Time magazine
said it was the closest to a real trial
that the accused assassin of President
Kennedy would ever have uh it was while
I was preparing for that trial and
during the trial that I learned about
two things number one I learned that the
very things that the conspiracy
theorists were accusing the Warren
Commission of ie
suppressing the evidence distorting the
evidence it was they who were guilty of
these precise things the second thing I
learned is that these conspiracy
theories of their
at first blush some of them may be
intellectually palatable but they did
not withstand scrutiny and I just
determined that there was just no
substance to all these charges and yet
the vast majority of Americans even
today believe in a conspiracy theory
they have rejected the findings of the
Warren Commission so at that point that
I decided to write a book way back in
1986 and I started working on it in 86
finally finished it's difficult for me
to speak candidly about reclaiming
history Paul is saying that I've had
three books number one in the New York
Times and I never bragged about those
books I just just didn't do it the
problem I have here and speaking
candidly about reclaiming history is
that if I'm candid it sounds like I'm
very immodest which is not good
although Churchill taught us that
modesty is not always a a virtue he was
running for re-election against Clement
Attlee and one of the reporters said Mr
Weston I think you have to agree mr.
atley's a lot more modest than you
whereupon Churchill said yes but then
again he's got much more to be modest
about in any event it's difficult for me
to speak candidly about it because I
sound like I'm boasting but the
alternative is even worse now what's the
alternative well if I don't speak
candidly about it people could believe
that this is just another book on the
assassination out of the close to 1000
and I'm sorry but it's not just another
book the Los Angeles Times said that
finally someone has put all the pieces
together reclaiming history I think
their words were is a book for the ages
and I found that interesting because
when I was writing this book whatever I
do whether it's the summation to the
jury or writing a book I always aspire
to a masterpiece whether I achieve it or
not as a completely different issue but
I at least aspire to it and I want it to
write a book for the ages meaning that
as long as people are interested in the
Kennedy assassination and they've been
interested in this case more than any
other murder case in world history with
us a hundred years from now or a
thousand years from now
this is a book reclaiming history that
they're gonna have to read so I was
interested when the LA Times used the
same words Wall Street Journal said that
reclaim me reclaiming history is unlike
any other book ever written on the
assassination so tonight I'm gonna sound
a little bit like I'm boasting here and
there but the alternative is you know
this is just another book it's not just
another book for all types of reasons
very briefly reclaiming history is the
first book this is not a boast the first
book on the assassination ever to cover
the entire case notebook is they've ever
even attempted to cover the entire
assassination I've got stuff in the book
relevant stuff that's not even in the
Warren Report of the House Select
Committee on assassinations report
secondly it had always been the
conventional with conventional wisdom
that there would never even by people
like myself who believe that Oswald
killed Kennedy and acted alone it had
always been the conventional wisdom that
there would never be a satisfactory
resolution to this case that there
always be some doubt I believe that many
people who read the book believe that
reclaiming history settles all the
questions about the Kennedy
assassination once and for all the LA
Times review says with reclaiming
history from this point forward no
reasonable person let's underline the
word reasonable no reasonable person can
argue that Lee Harvey Oswald was
innocent no sane person can take
seriously assertions that Kennedy was
killed by the CIA Castro the mob the
Soviets Texas oilmen or his Vice
President Lyndon Johnson each may be
guilty of crimes but not had anything to
do with Kennedy's assassination
reclaiming history may finally move
those accusations beyond civilized
debate the third thing about reclaiming
history it's the first book surprisingly
ever to take on all of these conspiracy
theorists and destroy their theories
there's been no other book that's done
that there's been books have taken on a
couple of theories but this takes on
every one of the theories and I think
successful in in destroying those those
theories my editor in New York Starling
Lawrence said it took a book of this
magnitude to finally put a stake in the
heart of the conspiracy movement in this
country the book is one and a half
million words quite long obviously if we
assume that the average book is about
400 pages and the average number of
words per page is 300 then this
translates into about 13 volumes which
we find the publisher which we shoehorn
into one book of about 1600 and some
pages and then there's also a CD with
another 11 hundred and 25 pages there's
also over 10,000 citations I think it's
the most sourced well certainly it's the
most sourced Kennedy assassination book
ever and someone said it may be the most
source non-fiction book ever with over
10,000 citations
there's one thing about me that I take
pride in I never ever ever make a charge
without supporting it you may not agree
with me but I just don't make a charge
and it's just just go on how often do
you read the newspaper you see a very
assertive declarative caption and then
you search in vain and the article for
the proof and either you find nothing at
all or something very anemic that's not
my style I say something I support it
you may not agree with me but I offer
support and that's those over 10,000
citations
why is this book so long my editor said
he has a nightmare of this elderly woman
and she's lying down in bed at night
she's reading the book
falls asleep while she's reading the
book and she doesn't wake up apparently
crushes her
Cindy Adams Niang Cindy Adams is she's
calling us with New York Post she said
that you start reading reclaiming
history I think she said in grammar
school and you finish as a senior
citizen you said this is not a book that
you put on the coffee table this is the
coffee data so why is it so long well
number one number one it's long because
as I said it's the first book to cover
the entire case but that's not really
the main reason why this book is so long
that's certainly one of the big reasons
the main reason this book is so long is
because of two realities actually
actually the second of two realities the
first reality is that at its core this
is a very very simple case very simple
Chief Justice Earl Warren it used to be
the DA of Oakland County and he said
that if when he was DEA this would have
been a two or three day murder case and
I agree with him within hours of the
shooting here in Dealey Plaza local law
enforcement ie the police department
sheriff's office local offices the FBI
it was obvious to them that AHS would
have killed had killed Kennedy and once
they found out his background this
incredible kook they formed the opinion
and they felt very strongly about it
that he must have acted alone so within
probably 24 hours local law enforcement
here was convinced that Oswald killed
Kennedy and acted alone so at its core
this is a very simple case and it
remains a simple case at its core to
this very day
that's one reality but there's another
reality the other reality is because of
the unceasing fanatical obsession of
literally this is not an exaggeration
literally thousands upon thousands of
Warren Commission critics and conspiracy
theorists who have investigated every
conceivable aspect of this case for
close to 44 years and made hundreds upon
hundreds of allegations this simple case
has been transformed into its present
state and what's this present state I'll
tell you what it is its present state is
that this murder case is the most
complex murder case by far and world
history nothing even remotely comes
close to it
just to give you an example in
manuscript form one of my end knows I'm
not talking about the text now talking
about an end note on acoustics ran to
about 120 pages with about 60 footnotes
so we're talking about a case that at
its core is simple but it's no longer
simple and I got kind of sucked into the
abyss and I couldn't get out and it just
never ended until my editor said Vince
we're gonna press if he hadn't told me
that I wouldn't be here tonight I spoke
to the Salesforce in New York several
months ago and I said you know I'll take
primary primary responsibility for the
length of this this book I said but
there's someone else in this room here
that's gotta at least take one percent
responsibility for the length of this
book and my editor knew I was talking
about him about five years ago I'm
having breakfast with him but I hardly
took time off for anything seven days a
week you know 70 80 90 hundred hours a
week so I'm having breakfast with him in
Pasadena yeah his name is Starling
Lawrence I call him stars and star I'm
sorry I apologize the book has gotten
out of hand
it's an obviously I'm gonna start having
to tighten very very heavily and I will
not say that he levitated that would be
an exaggeration but he literally can't
I'm not exaggerating he literally came
forward and Celia no I don't want you to
take out a word those were his words no
I want you to take out a word it kind of
surprised me cuz editors are always
cutting out paragraphs even chapters and
star who it's kind of a great guy great
editor but he's a little stingy with his
compliments I had two other number one
bestsellers with him he didn't say
anything about him he said no this is a
historic book this is a great book he
said great three times I don't sit they
kind of work so I told the sales people
you know stars got to take part of the
blame for the length of this book with
any project in life I'm taking my time
here so it may go over longer but you
know unless you have to close the place
I want to speak for maybe a half hour
with any project in life all of us
intuitively we don't even have to give
it a second thought we know that if we
work law
hard enough we're gonna reach the bottom
of the pile we don't even get a second
talk but I am here to tell you and there
other people that know it as well as I
do there is no bottom to the pile and
the Kennedy assassination right now as
I'm talking to you there's probably a
hundred people out there in this country
working full-time looking at some
document from the National Archives for
some inconsistency discrepancy
contradiction some little hint of a
conspiracy probably a hundred people
working full time probably a thousand
part-time so there is no bottom to the
pile in the Kennedy assassination and
when you get thousands of intelligent
people I don't think they're too
intelligent on this case but otherwise
intelligent people doctors lawyers
engineers putting all of their energy
and attention and intelligence on a
project like this they can create a lot
of mischief and they've done that as you
may or may not know seventy five percent
of the American people according to the
last poll believe in a conspiracy only
nineteen percent except the findings of
the Warren Commission now why is that
well my opinion the reason for that is
that through their their their books and
radio and TV talk shows and movies
college lectures etc the shrill voice of
the conspiracy theorists finally
penetrated the consciousness of the
American people and succeeded in totally
discrediting the Warren Commission and
convincing the vast majority of
Americans that Oswald was either a part
of some high-level conspiracy or just
some Patsy who was framed by some exotic
and elaborate group of conspirators
ranging from anti-castro Cuban exiles to
organized crime working in league with
US intelligence but it's all nonsense
it's all silliness after the snow and
movie came out JFK by the way he's not
gonna like me probably already does not
flex me
well his movie just one can say it
publicly it's one continuous lie no I
should amend that I should have been
there you got the date right I might
want to be fair at all he got the
location right and he got the victim
right so I've got to be fair but other
than that it was one continuous lie
shortly after the film I was speaking to
about 600 trial lawyers at a on East
Coast not on the Kennedy case but I gave
a speech called
tactics and techniques in the trial of a
criminal case and during the Q&A period
that followed there were some questions
asked about the Kennedy assassination
and I could tell by the rhetorical tone
of the question that the questioner
believed that there was a conspiracy so
I asked for show of hands how many of
you folks believe in a conspiracy in a
fast you know number just a forest of
hands were elevated seem like 90 percent
of the audience I said what if I could
convince you people when you're all
intelligent people although some people
may quarrel with that assessment about
lawyers but I said what if I could
convince you in less than one minute
that you're not thinking very clearly
about this case you're not thinking
intelligently about this case in less
than a minute I said and it was kind of
a murmur out there what's this guy
talking about you know finally someone
shouted off in the referee what we don't
think you can do it I said all right you
start looking at your watch let's see if
I can do it
I don't remember my exact words but
here's the essence of it I said I'd like
to have another show of hands of people
who either saw the JFK movie that has
just come out or at any time in the past
read a book or a magazine article or a
column propounding the conspiracy theory
or otherwise rejecting the findings of
the Warren Commission again this vast
forest of hands look like the same
number of people as before I said I
don't need a show of hands for my second
point I said I think you'll all agree
that before you form an intelligent
opinion upon a matter in dispute you
should hear both sides of the story like
the Old West Virginia Mountaineers said
no matter how thin I make my pancakes
they always have two sides I said with
that thought in mind
how many of you read the Warren Report
it was embarrassing
five ten hands were raged it was
embarrassing I proved my point
someone said it was about 47 seconds
they had formed an opinion rejecting the
findings of the Warren Commission and
they hadn't read the Warren Report if I
could condense the billions upon
billions of words written on this case
on the two main issues that Oswald
killed Kennedy and was there a
conspiracy let's see if I can do that in
a couple of minutes on each of these
issues with respect to Oswald's guilt
for my career as a prosecutor and I
think this is just common sense you
don't have to be a prosecutor if you're
innocent of a crime chances are there's
not going to be any evidence at all
pointing towards your guilt nothing at
all why because you're innocent but now
and then because of the nature of life
and the unaccountability of things now
and then there may be a piece of
evidence pointing towards your guilt
even though you're innocent and in very
unusual in rare cases maybe even two
things maybe even three things pointing
directly at your guilt even though
you're completely innocent but in this
case here everything that Oswalt did
everything he said all the physical
evidence all the scientific evidence
everything points towards Oswald's guilt
in reclaiming history I set forth
fifty-three pieces of evidence pointing
towards Oswald's guilt and under those
circumstances it would not be humanly
possible let me reiterate that under
those circumstances with 53 pieces of
evidence pointing towards bill it would
not be humanly possible for Oswalt to be
innocent at least not in the world in
which we live you know I'm talking to
you folks you can hear me there's gonna
be a dawn tomorrow not in that world
only in a fantasy world can you have
fifty three pieces of evidence pointing
towards your guilt
and still be innocent let me just go
over a couple of the pieces of evidence
with you mat Oswald's mannlicher-carcano
rifle it was the murder weapon I mean
come on that's pretty strong evidence
right the murder weapon was Oswald's
of all the stock boys here in the
building he's the only one that flees
the building after the shooting does a
roll call where's Oswald he's the only
one that took off 45 minutes later
Oswald shoots and kills officer JD
Tippit Dallas Police Department I told
the jury in London that that murder bore
the signature of a man in desperate
flight from some awful D thirty minutes
later
Oswald resists arrest pulls a gun on the
arresting officer during his
interrogation he told one provable lie
after another all of which show a
consciousness of guilt one lie he told
showed a couple things
number one he was lying and number two
he was pretty sure he said I've never
owned a rifle in my life so they show
him a photograph the backyard photograph
holding the Carcano he says well that's
my head but was superimposed in someone
else's body pretty quick thinking when
people tell me that they think Oswald is
innocent and most of the major authors
at great conspiracy books they don't
just talk about conspiracy they talk
about Oswald being innocent and I got
the quotes in the book when they tell me
that they think Oswald's innocent I know
one of two things
they're either completely unaware of the
evidence or they're just some silly
person now I want to read to you if I
can find it here I did come prepared to
the point right I put a little tag here
oh boy what page is it on 953 it's gonna
take a little time but I think it's
pretty important if I may say so myself
here's what I write if there was one and
only one contribution to the
assassination debate I would want to
make over and beyond the substance of
this book it's the obvious notion that
once you prove the positive or negative
of a matter in dispute all other
questions about the correctness of the
conclusion become irrelevant they only
have a legitimate life if the matter has
not yet been proved put another way the
answers to all other questions dealing
with the correctness of a conclusion are
rendered moot and academic by the answer
to the Seminole question hence once you
truly prove the earth is round
all questions about whether it is flat
become irrelevant with respect to the
Kennedy assassination once you establish
and no and we know not just beyond a
reasonable doubt but beyond all doubt
that Oswald killed Kennedy once you
establish and know that Oswald is guilty
as has been done then you also
necessarily that's the word we want to
italicize you also necessarily know that
there is an answer paren whether the
answer is known or not
and Brent compatible with this
conclusion for the endless alleged
discrepancies inconsistencies and
questions the conspiracy theorists have
raised through the years about Oswald's
guilt this they simply do not understand
if they did in all probability their
voice with finally after more than 40
years be silenced their inability or
unwillingness to grasp this fundamental
reality is the precise reason why
questions about Oswald's guilt will be
broached by conspiracy theorists as long
as chickens lay eggs if they don't have
a satisfactory answer to any of their
never-ending questions per in one among
thousands : something as obscure as
whether it was Oswald or an imposter who
allegedly signed Oswald's name - a guest
register at a restaurant in North Dakota
in 1963 and paren
without thinking they automatically feel
the question of Oswald's guilt is still
unresolved in other words every event
incident piece of information
inconsistency and so on is segregated
and becomes the whole story in itself
nothing is part of the whole each
incident is its own whole what the
Warren Commission critics and conspiracy
theorists seem incapable of seeing is
that the answers to their countless
questions are irrelevant since Oswald's
guilt has already been conclusively
established by other evidence now if it
hadn't then indeed there are many
unresolved questions would have to be
addressed and in a footnote I give a
couple examples for instance since we
know that Oswald shot and killed Kennedy
we also know that questions such as what
is the small object resembling a bullet
fragment that dr. David Mantic has
become obsessed with believing it was
planted in an autopsy x-ray to frame
Oswald by indicating he shot from the
rear whatever happened to the missing
autopsy photos was Oswald a good shot or
not
why wasn't commissioned exhibit number
399 damaged more than it was whom did
Roger Craig see running out of the Book
Depository building 15 minutes after the
assassination and getting into a Nash
Rambler did Oswald have time to get to
tenth and Patton from his rooming house
in time to kill officer Tippit why
doctors Gary Aguilar Cyril Wecht and Rex
Bradford want to know do they test
bullet fire through a test skull caused
more damage to the right side of the
skull then commissioned exhibit number
399 caused to the right side of
Kennedy's skull what is the reason for
the sharp dent on the lip lip of one of
the three cartridge cases found on the
floor of the sniper's nest
Josiah Thompson believes would have
prevented it from being loaded with
Oswald's rifle and hundreds upon
hundreds of other questions and problems
the critics have with the case against
Oswald they're all irrelevant why
because we know we know that Oswald
killed Kennedy so by definition there
has to be a satisfactory answer for all
of these questions and perceived
discrepancies and problems with the case
this is not an opinion I am giving this
is not an opinion I am giving this is an
encounter of
an incontrovertible fact of life and
logic they would only have relevance if
the guilt of Oswald hadn't already been
established beyond all doubt but it has
I'm sorry I took up all that time and I
think it's pretty important because it
deals with an issue now on the issue of
conspiracy I say in the book that I'm
satisfied beyond all doubt that Oswald
killed Kennedy I'm only satisfied beyond
a reasonable doubt that there was no
conspiracy I mean I believe I'd bet
anything on it that there was no
conspiracy but I think would be a little
unprofessional for me to say but I
believe beyond all doubt there was no
conspiracy why when number one Oswald is
dead number two it's a little more
difficult to prove a negative than a
positive by the way in a courtroom you
know when you make an allegation
you've got the burden of proof so the
conspiracy theorists would say there's a
conspiracy they've got the burden of
proof I on the other side and people
like me we don't have the burden to
prove a negative but in the book we
claim in history I set forth 32 reasons
all strongly indicating that there was
no conspiracy in this case so what I
just read to you applies to conspiracy
almost as much as it does now as well as
guilt let's talk about conspiracy very
briefly again we're summarizing billions
of words there's no credible credible
evidence that the CIA or mob or military
industrial complex or any of these other
groups were behind the assassination all
we have is a naked assertion of this
fact well they also argue motive the
main reason why lay people believe that
there's a conspiracy in the
assassination and the main argument that
conspiracy theorists use to support
their position of a conspiracy that such
as such a group had a motive
you know the military-industrial complex
murdered Kennedy because he was gonna
withdraw from Vietnam and they wanted to
have a war so they killed him
the mob killed Kennedy because they
wanted to get Bobby the Attorney General
brother off their back the CIA killed
Kennedy their motive as if they thought
Oswalt I mean they thought Kennedy was
soft on communism so they killed him
you know and when a president of the
United States is doing something that a
particular group doesn't like like like
the military or Wall Street or the
unions or the military I think I already
mentioned the military uh
environmentalists they don't like what
the president they said the children I
mean that's what we routinely do in
America they don't like what the
president is doing we count the the
reality is that motive doesn't mean that
much and yet these conspiracy theorists
devote entire books to establish a
motive and once they establish the
motive they think they're all the way
home the silly ridiculous Oliver Stone
finds 10 groups with a motive to go
Kennedy's got all 10 involved but really
yet ten groups involve assassination and
then you also hear people say well they
have whole chapters conspiracy book
chapter not only motive they say but
means an opportunity whoa that's heavy
well when I was a prosecutor I mean I
was I had heard the term but I didn't
know of any experienced prosecutors that
they use the term like that every
doesn't mean much I'll show you how the
Lord means he's coming to Dallas right
the president he said we're coming at
the neck country because Dallas was
extremely conservative back then so
there are a lot of people that hated
Kennedy for civil rights bills so they
had a motive right they hated them and
that's what we do you hate the president
you kill him what about means all I have
to do is buy a rifle or a gun right
what about opportunity all they have to
do is get here on Elm Street and they
got the mocha motive means an
opportunity but when you're in a
courtroom the real world you know I can
hear a courtroom wag say okay okay okay
had motive means and opportunity but did
he do it did he do it and all these
people at the point to is motive and
they make this naked speculation they
don't have any credible evidence showing
that any of these groups for behind the
assassination I told the jury in London
a dot a Dallas jury
I said I'll stipulate I'll agree with
you folks that three people can keep a
secret I said but only if two are dead
and here we're talking about now close
to forty four years later and not one
single word not one syllable that's
credible as leaked on I'm not talking
about some guys say my father killed
Kennedy and find out the father's behind
bars or something
at the time I'm talking about credible
evidence not one word
not one syllables leaked out and close
to 44 years showing that any of these
groups were behind the assassination
number two there's no evidence that
Oswald was connected to any of these
groups in any way whatsoever and believe
me they have behind conducted an
extremely thorough investigation I think
it was Harold Weisberg one of the the
great assassination critics I say great
because Harold was an honest man wrote
many books on the case and I think it
was Harold who said you know they
checked out every breath that this guy
ever breathed from the moment he arrived
back in the United States from the
Soviet Union I think was June 13 1962 to
the dated assassination that conducted
25,000 interviews they found no evidence
that Oswald was connected with any of
these groups number three let's assume
that one of these groups said we want to
kill the president I rejected out of
hand and belongs in a Robert Ludlum
novel no and I say I reject it out of
hand not my book I didn't quote a great
number of pages to all these crazy
theories but I'm telling you that the
notion of let's say the Joint Chiefs of
Staff sitting around a conference table
or wherever they are it's wherever they
want to go some mountain retreat with
the heads of major corporations the
military-industrial complex saying let's
murder President Kennedy I rejected out
of hand it's silly where was I look at
my notes so there's no evidence that any
of these groups decided to go Kennedy
but let's assume just for the sake of
argument that one of these groups like
the CIA said let's murder
President Kennedy Oswald obviously would
be one of the last people on the face of
this earth that they would go to to be
the hit man I mean come on why why
number one he wasn't an expert shot he's
a good shot but he was not an expert
shot you're gonna pull off the crime of
the century you had an expert shot
number two he had a $12 mail-order rifle
number three notoriously unreliable
extremely unstable here's a guy that
defects to the Soviet Union pre
Gorbachev
even today who in the world defects to
the Soviet Union one of the bleakest
places on the face of the earth and what
does he do when he gets over there he
wants to become a citizen they say no he
tries to commit suicide slashes his
wrists just just the exact type of guy
that the CIA or mob would say this is a
type of guy we want to rely on to commit
the biggest murder in American history
I understand fine let's take it a step
further that one of these groups that
let's kill the president but for
whatever crazy strange bizarre reason
they want Oswald to be their hip Pam
let's see if where that takes us makes
any sense
after Oswald fled that the Book
Depository building one of two things
would have happened let me tell you the
least likely thing first the least
likely thing is that there would have
been a car waiting for him to help him
escape down to Ecuador or wherever
that's the least likely scenario they
would certainly wouldn't want their hit
man to be apprehended and interrogated
by the authorities but I think you know
what I'm gonna say that the most likely
scenario by far by far you have to know
what I'm gonna say already if the mob or
the CIA is behind Oswald they're behind
this whole thing you have to know there
would have been a car waiting for him
somewhere around here a Elmen Houston
somewhere around here waiting for him to
drive him to his death you have to know
that yet he's on the street we know with
13 dollars in his pockets trying to flag
down buses and cabs no sensible person
could possibly believe that the CIA or
mob would permit something like that the
parade route that brought him right
beneath the window the motorcade route
that wasn't even determined until
November 18th 1963 four days before the
assassination it wasn't in the papers as
I recall until the next day Dallas
Morning News November 19th does any
rational person actually believe that
the CIA or what-have-you would conspire
with Oswald to murder
Kennedy three or four days before the
president visited Dallas that just
moonshine it's crazy
no one has ever accused me being short
winded but I want to leave enough time
here for questions and answers but
there's two things that I do want to get
into before we open this up to questions
and answers because they were so
important to the trial in London and one
is the ìiî so most of you people here
tonight are very familiar and read books
on the assassination so you all know
about the head snap to the rear that
head snap to the rear was first shown on
national television I think was for Aldo
Rivera's show good night America 1975
and millions of Americans saw Kennedy
going down Elm and all of a sudden this
head going back eight inches the
inference being what well that the shot
must have come from the front where the
grassy knoll is not from the rear where
Oswald was had snapped his rear in
London Spence showed that segment of the
Zapruder film five times I didn't even
object he said look like Babe Ruth had
struck the president from the front he
said the mr. bull yo see here is trying
to convince you folks that what you saw
with your very own eyes you didn't
really see here's the answer to that and
if I haven't had the answer the verdict
in London almost assuredly would have
been not guilty it would've been a
reasonable doubt of guilt but I did have
an answer here's the answer and many of
you probably already know it and I have
the photos in the book you have to look
at the individual frames so this is pure
film you cannot see it if you look at
the film you have to look at the
individual frames you look at frame 3:12
and I showed the jury in London on the
screen 312 the president's heads okay at
3:13 118th of a second later they're 18
point 3 frames per second on the
Zapruder film the president is struck in
the head was explosion to the head and
in what direction is the president
president's head pushed at 3:13 slightly
forward 2.3 inches not backwards but
forward indicating one shot from the
rear so at the all-important mome
of impact the president's head was
pushed forward not backwards indicating
a shot from the rear there was a key key
issue in London if I hadn't put those
frames on a screen for the jury I think
their verdict would have been not guilty
I also showed the Dallas jury in London
a high contrast photo frame 3:13 it
shows this terrible spray of blood and
tissue and it's all to the front
indicating a shot from the rear the
Magic Bullet conspiracy theorists are so
bold sellout rages that not only did
they lie about things where there's
documentary evidence controverting what
they're saying they go beyond that they
literally lie when there's photographic
evidence film evidence proving that
they're lying
they don't care why because their
audience may be only one out of a
hundred no no the truth and what they do
in their sketches and I've got the
sketch in the book they place governor
Connally seated directly in front of
Kennedy in their sketches and it was in
the Oliver Stone movie the same thing
directly in front and they argue that a
bullet coming from the Book Depository
building six floor window
right to left passing through soft
tissue on a straight line to hit
Connally they say would have to make a
right turn in midair and then a left
turn to hit Connally bullets don't do
that it's a magic bullet the single
Bullet theory is dead that's what they
argue the only problem is that if you
start out with an erroneous premise
everything that follows makes a heck of
a lot of sense but the problem is that's
all wrong Connally was not seated
directly in front of Kennedy I think
most you folks know that he was seated
to the left front of President Kennedy
in a jump seat a half a foot in
I got photographs I got one very good
photograph in the book and his pretty
film shows that so they flat-out lie
knowing people that do this right
sketches they know that Conley was not
seated directly in front of Kennedy and
still they put him that way
why so they can argue the magic bullet
in London Spence that dr. Cyril Wecht on
the stand he probably knows Cyril he's a
former mayor former um corner of
Allegheny County and Pittsburgh so he
asked Cyril Wecht dr. Wecht characterize
for this jury there's this bullet and of
course quack said well it was like a
magic bullet that doesn't even exist in
cartoons making rights and left turns in
midair a cross-examination I said the
dr. Wecht now dr. Wecht if this bullet
which is passing on a straight line
through soft tissue and Kennedy's body
which which you concede because he
admitted that I said if it did not go
out to hit Connally which you say it did
not why didn't a tear up the interior of
the limousine or hit the driver he says
I don't know I didn't conduct the
investigation in this case so I says
well dr. Wecht it looks like you folks
are the ones that have a magic bullet
here if it didn't go on to hit Connally
or tear up the interior of the limousine
or hit the driver I said it must have
cigs AG to the left he said no it need
not have zigzag to the left I said that
a hop skip and jump over the car he said
no it need not have performed any
remarkable feat at all I said well then
dr. lett tell this Dallas jury what
happened to that bullet his answer was I
don't know so who's got the magic bullet
here for over 40 years the conspiracy
theorists have rapped that magic bullet
around the Warren Commission's neck and
the majority of Americans think the
Warren Commission had a magic bullet but
the only people that had a magic bullet
here are the conspiracy theorists
because if we believe then once that
bullet exited the president's throat it
literally vanished into thin air without
a trace so who's got the magic bullet
after over 40 years of the most
prodigiously intensive investigation and
examination of a murder in world history
certain powerful facts exists which
cannot be challenged
number one not one weapon other than
Oswald's manicure Carcano was ever found
and linked to the assassination not one
weapon other than Oswald's manicure
Carcano not one bullet other than the
three fired from Oswald's weapon was
ever found and linked to the
assassination no person other than
Oswald has ever been connected by any
credible evidence to the assassination
only Oswald this is close to forty four
years now
thousands of investigators they come up
just empty-handed no evidence is ever
surface as I indicated before linking
Oswald to any of these groups believed
to be behind the assassination and no
evidence has ever been found showing
that any person or group murdered Oswald
and framed or murdered President Kennedy
and framed Oswald for the murder that
they committed no one would think that
faced with these stubborn and immutable
realities that the conspiracy theorists
unable to pay the piper would folder
Kent and go home but instead undaunted
and unfazed they continue to disgorge
even more of what they've given us for
the last close to 40 years and that's
just wild speculation theorizing and
intentional dissembling of the facts
okay I went longer and I should have I
have a tendency being a little off it
was an article not 2 20 years ago
somehow I me to write on an important
subject let's give this we're gonna give
you thirty five hundred words as I can't
say hello in thirty five hundred words
ended up 7,500 they pups of hopefully
I'm sure I took as much time as I did
but let's hope another questions and
answers I know there's some real strong
really strong conspiracy theorists out
there you're gonna ready to hit me with
some some tough questions yes sir beyond
Lee Harvey Oswald being the lone
assassin on the sixth floor there was a
photograph of the grassy knoll the
wooden fence and some trees with an
alleged person behind the trees did any
of your research ever get into that area
well yeah the whole grassy knoll area I
get into in considerable depth and the
photographic panel the House Select
Committee on assassinations they
enhanced that whole area there and they
saw nothing at all yet conspiracy if
they're to see all types of people there
with rifles no one else can see it I
think there are 14 photographic experts
on the House Select Committee it may be
even been 21 I forget some of the facts
but anyway at least 14 photographic
experts from top institutions throughout
the country they try to make that area
is clearer and enhance it as much as
possible they saw absolutely nothing and
that's in the House Select Committee
report the grassy knoll when you stop to
think about it know that we're talking
about it
how much sense does it make if you're
firing from the grass you know that's
the president's right okay it was right
front you're firing from the right
there's got to be some inference wounds
if the bullets are coming from the right
to the right side of the president's
body there were no entrance wounds
according to the wall the Warren
Commission House Select Committee no
entrance wounds to the right side of the
president's body only two bullet
entrance wounds in dr. Wecht himself
agrees both to the back side of the
president one the upper right back exit
to the front of the throat and then
there was one bullet that entered the
upper right part of his head and exited
the right front of his head but both
entrance wounds are to the president's
back so if the shots came from the grass
you know by definition you would have
had entrance wounds to the right side of
the president's body there weren't any
furthermore the shot
at frame 313
from the so called picket fence it's
about 35 yards very very close bullet
traveling 2,000 feet a second weighs a
third of an ounce that bullet most
likely is gonna pass right through the
President's head or body isn't it an
absolute minimum isn't it gonna go over
into the left side of his body a third
of an ounce traveling at 2,000 feet a
second the head will
the autopsy surgeon said the left
hemisphere the president's head of brain
was quote intact unquote if a bullet
came from the grass you know obviously
there would have been an injury to the
left side of his body most likely exit
wounds there was nothing at all no one
saw anyone with a weapon with a rifle on
the grassy knoll no weapon no expended
cartridges from a weapon were found
there it didn't happen when you stopped
to think about it it really doesn't even
make that much sense because with all
eyes going to the front or most of the
eyes going to the front and the
presidential motorcade if you're a
sniper forget about Oswald for a moment
whoever killed Kennedy was a sniper
headlines New York Times next day
Kennedy killed by sniper not one of
these fellows like Hinckley who tried to
kill President Reagan in front of
everyone it was a sniper if you're a
sniper and you want to get away are you
gonna position yourself to the front
where you're within the range of vision
of most of the people driving down the
street I don't think so you're do it
Oswald did most of the eyes are looking
forward and he picks the president off
from the back and if you go to that
window I'm sure most of you have been
there and you imagine holding a rifle
that barrel is virtually on a straight
line with Elm Street also limousine is
only probably 11 and a half miles an
hour there's a 3.9 degree declination to
Elm Street the relevance of that is that
it eliminates the necessity of elevating
the muzzle as the limousine gets farther
away from the sixth floor window I asked
my firearms guy from Wisconsin in London
I said I don't want to put any words in
your mouth I said but was the president
essentially a stationary target he said
yes the president the same
he was a stationary target the grassy
knoll actually would have been a more
difficult shot why because the limousine
is passing from left to right it's a
moving target as you go up to the window
as that limousine was going in the
southwesterly direction it's almost a
straight shot the conspiracy theorists
also lie they say you know no one's ever
duplicated what Oswald did it's just not
true absolutely not true during the
Warren Commission period a specialist
Miller in the army duplicated with
Oswald did CBS in 1967 we had a firearm
specialist beat what Oswald did my
firearms guy in London beat what Oswald
did so they just tell these lies they
also say Oswald could hit the broadside
of a barn
some of them say it that's another lie
he's a sharpshooter he fired her 212 in
the military not an expert but he's a
sharpshooter and then the others go the
other way and say no one could do what
he did could fire three shots and they
say in only 5.6 seconds well it's more
than 5.6 Sexson the first shot at 160
that's what most people believe third
shot at 313 8.4 seconds so we stop think
about it the clock only starts to run
from the first shot because the first
shot the cartridge is already in the
chamber they've already a he's already
aimed forget about Oswald whoever it was
so he's got 8.4 seconds to fire two
shots now it gets a little more
sophisticated than that I'm just telling
you that the conspiracy theorists have
not been truthful with the American
public and how great a shot was it I
think was a great shot why do you have
to be a great shot on the range is 100
200 300 and 500 yards the first shot hit
the president of 59 yards I think that
the shot that the head was 88 yards
lower than what is the measurement when
you fire for record in the military so
it's 59 yards 88 yards we assume that
Oswald's aiming at the head why but he's
trying to kill him this most vulnerable
part of his body first shot misses
completely second shot again this is the
target hits the upper right back the
third shot hits the head went on a three
talking about Oliver Stone whole silly
this burst it is
his movie he says and I'm not I'm not
making this up you can't make up stuff
like this because 240 it's too far out
how do you make up stuff like this in
his movie he says there are three
professional gunman I don't know where
they came from but around the world here
are the best shots in the world
according to Oliver 3 professional
gunman fired six shots at Kennedy now we
assume that these professional gunmen
are aiming at the head they're trying to
kill Kennedy right and Oliver says it
was a turkey shoot meaning it was so
easy in other words the present was just
a sitting duck and in my book I say
Oliver did you bother to read the
manuscript or whatever you call it the
script of your own movie did you bother
to read the script Oliver let me tell
you what Oliver Stone says how he says
how well these three gunmen did again
I'm quoting stone now is it three top
gunmen right it's a turkey shoot right
close range
almost a stationary target quarry -
Oliver the first shot missed the
limousine entirely so this is this
high-powered gunman at the military
industrial complex whoever hired not
only couldn't hit Kennedy couldn't even
hit the presidential limousine according
to all her stone but he hasn't read the
script apparently not
I don't think something wrong with him
is there gonna be some people thought of
things anything wrong at all and I think
he's pretty bright second shot hits the
president according to Oliver in the
throat that's not good enough Oliver
they're there to kill him the throat
shot wouldn't in fact you know Parkland
doctor said the bullet that entered the
upper right back connection to the
throat they felt the president would
have survived that it hadn't been for
the head shot so Oliver can't give you
credit for the second shot it did not
hit the target hit the throat third shot
according to stone hits the upper right
back again Oliver your professional
gunman expert top gunman hired by the
CIA missed the target fourth shot not
only doesn't hit Kennedy's head doesn't
hit his body misses his ba misses his
body completely and hit
Governor Connally v shot according to
Oliver Stone misses the limousine again
completely I mean did these guys earn
their money or their wage I don't think
so
the six shot hits the president in the
head it's one out of six or it's
embarrassing
that's embarrassing I'm embarrassed for
you Oliver no I am I really am
have you ever had someone on stage and
they're making a fool out of themselves
and you kind of turn away you know
because you don't want to see the
embarrassment I'm embarrassed for all of
us don't and I think that Oliver when he
goes to these cocktail parties in West
LA is gonna be looking at people so if
they read reclaiming history if so you
know he's gonna avert their glance it's
embarrassing what this guy did and
obviously he's not gonna like me yes sir
okay thank you mr. Bugliosi I enjoyed
your presentation thanks for coming
tonight and I'm looking forward to read
your book thank you just a general
question about your book and your
researcher in the last 20 years who was
the most interesting person you
interviewed for this book the most
interesting person I interviewed for
this book I have to say Marina a very
close friend of mine
Jack Duffy's here tonight leans towards
a conspiracy theory but he's saying now
he's reading my book I said Jack I hope
my book at least convinces you my friend
but there's no conspiracy anyway I
wanted to interview marina not because I
could learn anything from her she had
been interviewed you know hundreds of
hundreds of times and so she really had
nothing new to tell me I knew but
derivatively she's a historical figure
so Jack did a great job and located
marina she was working at an army
surplus store here in Dallas I think it
was November of 2000 other than Jack
anyway we walk in and Jack says Marina
this is Vincent Bugliosi I know who he
is I've seen him on TV
and I said well yeah we're not appeared
a couple times you said are you proud of
it
I won't say it went downhill from there
but I didn't get too much better either
and I spoke to her for about 45 minutes
not really about the facts of the case
because you know I knew that her mine
had been so impregnated with all these
crazy conspiracy theories that whatever
she told me was not a value but for
years as you all know she said that her
husband killed the president but some
factual matters came about and Jack said
marina did you take the backyard photos
and she said yes I did and Jack said
that settles that question you're aware
of Jack that she had already testified
to that that she took the backyard
photos I always have follow-up questions
and I tried to get in touch with her
again and when I called back the fellow
that answered the phone the army surplus
store was not been existence anymore and
it was being used for different purpose
but the fellow happened to know marina
very very well because she said or he
said that she used to babysit for him
not for him he was the child how do you
say that he was a child is she he was
she was his babysitter when you get old
you have all types of problems don't get
old okay anyway I said I want to talk to
Marina again I said nothing really
important I got a cup of course I always
have questions should fine I'll get in
touch there she she had known her for
over 30 years and that went on for about
three four or five months I kept calling
them and and I couldn't get her to
answer I said game I gave her my home I
have her home number but I wouldn't I
would never bother her there but I said
you know here's my home number or she
wants all I'll write the questions out I
just have a couple of questions and he
finally told me one day he said I'm not
gonna be able to get her to talk to you
and I said why he says well for some
some reason I've never seen marina
intimidated by anyone else in my life
except by you know I'm not an
intimidating person at all nothing in
Timmy you've seen me is there anything
intimidating about me
obviously not
and did she act intimidated when I walk
through the door I know who you are you
know so I don't know I don't know what
the story is they're the only thing I
can think of is she probably knew I did
my homework and I was prepared and maybe
that's why she found me intimidated I'm
not an intimidating person at all but so
I never spoke to her again but you asked
a very interesting question I would say
marina was the most interesting she's a
little more feisty I knew about 12
fights as she was but a little more
feisty than I thought she'd be let's
respect - marina here's something I
think it's very very interesting
I've worked seven days a week on this
book virtually round-the-clock I didn't
go anywhere I mean I had to postpone
dental medical appointments but I have a
friend an older fellow his wife always
trying to get me to go to the Opera I
don't like opera music but I kept saying
no and then one day said Vince I've
already bought the tickets there's
second row they're very expensive I
already bought them it's Carmen I think
you'll like that type of music I know
you like Latin standards incidentally I
put on an album called greatest latin
love songs of the century don't worry I
didn't sing they could never kid but I
put that out I like the Latin boleros
that came out of Cuba in Mexico in the
20s 30s and 40s anyway so I go to Carmen
no I can't waste the whole evening come
on I don't have any to waste but
something very important came out of
that evening I think Carmen who saw that
opera did any of you see it okay wasn't
she someone that seemed to just be
outside the reach of her suitors somehow
she's never give her suitors what she
knew that they needed and I said you
know I'm looking at marina here in
Oswald to a certain extent although he's
a male and I put that in the book Oswald
and marina had a tempestuous
relationship I think they loved each
other he started beating her she'd run
away he'd run after literally get down
on his knees and beg her to come back
and she'd come back they started beating
her again in the cycle will continue
that's not that unusual but there was
another aspect to their relationship
that is very relevant
to this case for some perverse reason
neither one could give the other what
they knew the other needed each one
seemed to be just beyond the reach of
the other like marina said you know
please don't ever send me back to Russia
and he would never say don't worry about
I'll never do that no he wouldn't he
wouldn't give her the the comfort of
knowing that she was going to stay in
America and she was the same way with
him now the night before the
assassination he goes out was a Thursday
night and he'd never gone out on a
Thursday night before he used to go out
with Buell Frazier Friday evening come
back Monday morning but this time he
goes on a Thursday evening to get his
rifle at Ruth Payne's garage in Irving
why obviously he intended to kill the
president but here's my position I may
be wrong I think it was conditional yes
he intended to kill the president but it
was conditional if marina would not take
him back and marina has testified that
that night he begged her was begging her
three times to come back to him I can
get you that used washing machine that
you want he's making a dollar 25 working
here in the building I think I he was
living in a closet big time hit man for
the mob right eight dollars a week
living in a closet I couldn't believe it
when I went out there in 1996 or
whatever was I said this is where he
lives it yeah like a large closet anyway
what am I saying
you know there's a problem when you get
old you go off on a tributary and say
where was I and no one can tell you
because no one's listening to you
okay I'm talking about marina and an
Oswald he begs her three times to the
back then she turned him down and her
testimony in front of Warren Commission
plane Carmen to the bitter end she said
I was smiling on the inside she was
happy that he was asking her to come
back but on the outside I was tough with
him wouldn't give him what he needed and
after the third time he became very
distant and we know what happened the
following day that night one time you're
lying in bed and her leg
touched his and he pushed it away
changed completely after the third time
my belief without knowing is that if she
had come back to him he would not have
shot the president the following day I
mean I just find it very very hard to
believe that he would have done that
marina herself says that she wrote a
letter to the Warren Commission and
Russian it was translated into English
she takes on the responsibility for the
murder she said if I had any idea what
he was gonna do the next day I mean come
on I would have taken him back I would
have gone back to him so I think there's
some some connection I can't be a
hundred percent sure but I'm I'm 99%
sure if she's he's telling her he's
gonna buy her use washing machine and
get an apartment I don't think he's [ __ ]
man the CIA the if you're the hit man
for the CIA or the mob the night before
the assassination you're telling your
wife you're gonna get her I used what
did I say I used washing machine it just
doesn't add up
okay okay
well III want to tell you folks that I'm
honored to speak here and thank you very
much for coming here tonight and I wish
all of you the very best of luck in all
years ago thank you very much
just give this will you'll see a chance
to get downstairs but hold your seats
for one second he's gonna sign books
he's gonna sign copies of this book and
this book only because there are a lot
of folks that want copies that we very
much appreciate your being here and
they've got a path opened up for you
there thank you for being here very much
give them a little bit of head start